normalerweise wäre diese Lagerhalle
jetzt komplett leer doch wie auch im
vergangenen Jahr gilt ein Verkaufsverbot
von Feuerwerkskörpern die
Geschäftsführerin der Firma Diamond
Feuerwerk Jessica Jürgs hat das Gefühl
sie ist zum Spielball der Politik
geworden aktuell sind hier drei große
Lagerhallen mit Pyrotechnik gefüllt ja
was soll man davon halten wir arbeiten
ein Jahr auf drei Tage wo wir verdienen
können hin ich kann nicht übermorgen
sagen ach ja okay Corona ist weniger die
Inzidenzen sind weniger dann verkaufe
ich dann mein Feuerwerk ich habe nur
drei Tage im Jahr
am 17 dezember hat der Bundesrat den
böllerverbot zugestimmt damit ist der
Verkauf von Feuerwerkskörpern
deutschlandweit verboten politisch
begründet wird das mit der hohen
Verletzungsgefahr
wir wollen die krankenhaushäuser davor
bewahren dass sie zu viele Notfälle
intensivfälle über Silvester und Neujahr
haben denn wir wissen aus den
vergangenen Jahren das gerade Silvester
und auch natürlich das Feuerwerk dazu
führen dass Menschen nicht ordentlich
damit umgehen sich schwer verletzen ins
Krankenhaus müssen und wir haben eine
sehr schwierige Situation in den
Krankenhäusern auf den Intensivstationen
in Niedersachsen ist jedes zehnte Bett
mit einem COBIT 19 Patienten gefüllt und
daher möchten wir einfach diese
Belastung ab vermeiden für Silvester
im henriettenstift in Hannover wird
gerade ein neuer corona-patient
aufgenommen die Belastung an Silvester
ist besonders hoch auch ohne Pandemie dr
Sven Wolf ist Leiter der Notaufnahme er
hat schon viele silvesternächte hinter
sich Verletzungen durch Feuerwerkskörper
sind an Silvester nicht das Hauptproblem
Punkt Mitternacht geht es dann los bis
zum nächsten Mittag eigentlich
da kommen dann pausenlos und
Rettungsdienst kommen fußläufige
Patienten das ist eigentlich jedes Jahr
immer absehbar auf der einen Seite halt
chirurgische Verletzungen durch durch
Glasscherben durch Böller auch auf der
anderen Seite spielt Alkohol leider
immer eine ganz große Rolle besonders
wenn Alkohol im Spiel ist wird die
Behandlung oft aufwendiger Wolf sorgt
sich außerdem um illegale Böller die für
ihn häufig zu deutlich schwereren
Verletzungen für die Bevölkerung ist es
das zweite Jahr in Folge ohne Feuerwerk
viele begrüßen das
also ich finde es super weil unsere
Tiere haben schrecklich Angst während
Silvester und für die ist das wunderbar
ich finde es schön wenn es vielleicht so
organisierte Feuerwerke gebe volllassen
Einschnitt in die
in die Tradition bedeutet für mich
Silvester gehört ein Feuerwerk dazu für
mich
also kein Freund von
[Musik]
Silvester schlafen nachts und von daher
juckt mich das ehrlich gesagt nicht so
habe ich kein Problem mit
Jessica Jörgs verdient ihren
Lebensunterhalt mit der Pyrotechnik Ihr
Unternehmen stellt ein weiteres Jahr
ohne Feuerwerk vor echte Probleme
wir haben 90 95% Umsatzverlust
und jeder kann sich ausmalen was das für
eine Unternehmen bedeutet egal welche
Branche es ist 90 95% Umsatzverlust wer
soll das auffangen
der Bund hat den betroffenen Unternehmen
Wirtschaftshilfen zugesagt die Branche
Bank trotzdem um ihre Zukunft
im Gegensatz zu den Jahren vor der
Pandemie dürfte es ein ruhiges Silvester
werden vielen dürfte das in diesem
turbulenten Zeiten ganz recht sein